this is sj a prehensile tailed skink  found in the solomon islands this little  guy is the largest known of its kind  [Music]  the prehensile tailed skink's body is a  greenish olive colour with scattered  black scales  this colouring combined with its slow  movements helps the skink to camouflage  with its surroundings and hide from  enemies  like other skinks its head is flat and  triangular  their strong legs and sharp claws help  them to climb trees  the defining feature on this skink is  its prehensile tail which allows them to  grasp objects and branches for balance  their tail makes up nearly half of their  body's length  the prehensile tailed skink's habitat is  under threat due to deforestation for  lumbar and agriculture  this and the skin's popularity within  the pet trade has threatened their  survival in the wild  this is the prehensile tailed skink  [Music]  you